welcome to the Sevilla I'm playing
Frankie J from the US and I'm I just
started with the fianchetto not thinking
much about the actual setup that I'm
going to choose symmetrical English here
there are many many interesting lines
that black can play this is one of them
the idea is just to go Queen d7 and
Bishop h3 okay it's been suggested let's
try this it's not entirely convincing
probably hear each form but once in a
while those kind of attacks do work if I
go h4 now he can just take it with the
night they don't have any particular
compensation maybe I can try to pin him
first him exchanging this Bishop for the
night could be a good idea strategically
anyway to control the form and I still
can play h4 now unless he said unless
he's playing edge for himself okay
I don't the Schneider I can I can
probably sure I do that I'm not sure I'd
like to develop it of course but I don't
want to block the bishop on g7 this is
why I'm going from my g7 yeah I've got
good enough control over deform due to
this useful pin G for Bishop pinning the
night also note that I have not
cancelled this might might be handy
later okay so just just taking or
anything but no let's just control the
important squares in the center as slab
canceled hmm I didn't want to cancel
first because sometimes they're vague
ideas of playing a g5 takes h4 and so on
but the siruni should work on on a very
very good day
okay Knight e5 ssible 95 just being
annoying I'm not quite sure what Bishop
g5 does
maybe he wants to play e5 and 94
something along those lines the moment I
don't really see a reason why I should
cancel after castling he can play Bishop
h6 exchange my bishop not terrible but
it's not clear that I should give up my
Bishop 27 that's a strong piece
controlling the long diagonal yeah man
the typical play here with b4 and b5
Drago b5 and he goes before I'm a bit
quicker
I wonder if the the weird idea night be
3 and then 95 worth considering to make
sure I play b5 without him responding
before who came this is so strange I
need to tested looks completely wacky
probably it is yeah I want to play B
five flex move and I want to stop him
playing before
Dwight an quite a strange idea maybe
it's a it's really rubbish ok um should
I take 194 then B 5 jo sang taek
this kind of trade is actually useful
for me because this is the notorious
superfluous night two nights competing
for the de for square I only need one of
them this is one of those things
described by mark tourette's key in his
books one of them yeah yeah I'm always a
bit critical about those books but this
is a very useful concept to know also
could've taken with the pawn of course
but I thought I have some play against
the b-pawn but this is not great no no I
would have liked to have the temple for
castles I mean every wrong sentence it
would have been great if I had castled
already this is what I was trying to say
okay it's nothing terrible but still
yeah
it takes a six-hour going to take before
I don't see a drawback besides that it
simplifies the position okay but I don't
think I'm I'm allowing anything terrible
he cannot use this rock reduce useful
[ __ ] see one that's 92 look a one also
92 until he only has this one check here
which I can simply answer with King h7
so I'm probably still attack more
comfortable
yeah I'd see two and taking them Bishop
before yeah this is actually a good idea
check okay should be for of course my
idea but then he's got look at three
weird moves but okay I can play f6 I can
play f6 which is important just covering
covering him King g7 was stronger than
he can be could have played he could
have played Queen Queen f8
let's see how to how to play this now
five
mm5 the right idea not sure not sure at
all hmm maybe can claim at least his
rook is now mobile again this is I'm
just forgetting - oops the time time
warning
just 12 seconds left check check check
Wow we're losing the stems completely
idiotic
check check check completely forgot the
clock at one point
look here I'm 30 seconds up and then I
just fought fell asleep now too much
medication for the coat
I don't know I mean black is just
clearly better in this position but I
have forgot to move around here I was
still time up and I spent 30 seconds
here
complete complete nonsense f5 SS is okay
but I'm just I'm just far too slow
Queen 870s just winning on f2 yeah it
does letter I've simply forgot to play
other than that it looked like a pretty
decent positional game
I'm always controlling the more
important squares around here this just
is a much better Bishop in comparison to
g2 now what I can try to explain better
at this stage is this thing with the
superfluous Knight this some idea is
about the square in d4 or any square
which is usually used by night the
central outpost or other outpost black
has two knights and only one night can
occupy the square therefore the c6
Knight is basically a superfluous piece
it doesn't do much besides looking at
the same square on the forwards Khaliq
has already posted and therefore
here 92 is a move that black welcomes
now I can exchange one night and now I
have two good pieces left against the
bad piece on g2 and this is why black is
also somewhat better in this position
it's not terribly serious but like is
slightly better and it became serious a
bit later alright thanks for watching